مساء الخير من عائشه السيفي
دخل الرئيس السوداني السابق الان عمر حسن
البشير الى السلطه انقلاب عسكري في العام
الف وتسعمائه وتسعه وثمانين وخرج منها
اليوم بانقلاب عسكري وصف ما جرى اليوم
بانقلاب عسكري ليس من على ولكنه وصف اطلقه
عدد من قاده الثوار
والمتظاهرين في الشارع السوداني اللي
اعتبر ان الغاره مجرد انقلاب قصر اللي
وصفه البعض وصف انه مبكر اليوم من الجيش
ليس استجابه
استجابه من الجيش لمطالب المتظاهرين ولكن
مجرد انقلاب قصر الحفاظ على النظام ده
السبب الاساسي فهمهم لما جاء في البيان
الاول لوزاره الدفاع او للجيش على لسان
وزير الدفاع في التلفزيون السوداني خلاصه
ما جاء في البيان انه ياسف على وجود شهداء
وجود جرحى وبات من ا الرحمه او بيدعوا
بالرحمه للقتلى وبيد ع والشفاء للجرحى
لكنه لا يتعدى شكل من الاشكال
القصاص لحقوق هؤلاء القتلى والجرحى وما
بيتكلم شها على محاسبه المسؤولين عن ما
ترى لهم مع انه المسؤوليه تقع بوضوع اما
على اجهزه امن التابعه للدوله اول مليشيات
كانت تابعه للرئيس البشير الامر الثاني
بنفس المنطقه ايضا انه يتبرا من ممارسات
النظام عمر حسن البشير لكنه لا يشير ابدا
من قريب او من بعيد الى محاكمته على كل
جرائمه السابقه وهي كثيره جدا على مدار
ثلاثين عاما الامر الاهم ام المتظاهرون
كانوا ياملون اذا استجاب الجيش لهم
وساعدهم في التخلص من الرئيس بشير يقوم
بتكوين او بانشاء حكومه مدنيه حكومه
تكنوقراط من المدنيين هي حكومه التكنوقراط
يعني مجموعه اصحاب الكفاءات المهنيه اللي
ما عندهمش اي توجهات سياسيه ممكن تؤثر على
قراراتهم يبقى حد بارع في الراي او في
الامن او في الخارجيه بس كفاءات نهايه
وانه لما يختار هذه الكفاءات يتم ذلك
بالتشاور مع المتظاهرين في الشارع واظن
انه تجمع المهاريين عمل اللجنه من خمسه
وعشرين من السودانيين المشهود لهم
بالكفاءه عشان الجيش يتشاور معهم فيما
يتعلق ب تكون الحكومه وفي وفيما يتعلق بال
خريطه الانترنت
المرحله الانتقاليه بصفه عامه لكن هذا لم
يتم وفوجئوا ان الجيش قرر فردا انه لا
يستعين حكومه مدنيه وانما يكون مجلس عسكري
لاداره شؤون البلاد وليس لفتره قصيره ولكن
لمده عامين وهي فتره كبيره
قرروا بين عامين في السودان وبين الفتره
الانتقاليه في البلد المجاور الجزائر اللي
هي ثلاثه شهور فقط لا غير بالاضافه طبعا
الى تعطيل الدستور وحل
اسست الرئاسه وحل الحكومه وحل حكومات
الولايات وفرض قانون الطوارئ ثلاثه شهور و
اه فرض حظر التجوال من العاشره مساءا الى
الرابعه صباحا يعني ال ال البيان في
العماله اعطى انطباعا ان الجيش حين
الرئيس البشير لم يفعل ذلك استجابه لضغوط
الطوارئ ولا لمطالبهم ولكنه فعلها بمنطق
انه عمليه جراحيه قام بها النظام لنفسه
للحفاظ على نفسه بمعنى انه يتخلص من رئيس
اصبح عبئا عليه يتخلص من الرئيس وبعض
معاونيه فقط حتى يبقى النظام في شكل اخر
وتحت اسماء موجوده
الحقيقه ان عاده في هذه الظروف اذا كان في
السودان والا في مصر والافريقيه والنفسيه
بعد هذا النوع من الثورات الشعبيه انه عم
بيقوم بشده ويحاول ان يبقى بيبقى
حتى لو كان ذلك عن طريق التخلص من بعد
عناصرهم نريد ان يبقى ليس فقط قبل السلق
ولكن خوفا من المساءله والمحاسبه لانه كل
جريمه ارتكبها البشير ومع اكثر جرائم وعلى
مدار ثلاثين عاما لا هو لم يتخذ قراراتها
لوحده ول واتخذ القرار منفردا فمن نفذ هذه
الجرائم او من نفذ هذه القرارات عدد كبير
جدا اللي هم بيشكلوا النظام السوداني على
مدار ثلاثين عاما في اخرين شايفين المساله
على النحو
ولكن بيضيفوا لها بعد اخر انه شايفين ان
الرئيس السوداني
ونظامه بالكامل نظام اسلامي اخواني طيب
وايه الفرق انه يكون نظام عادي ونظام يا
اخواني في الحالتين النظام ثبت فشله
الفرقه بس انه لو انه النظام اخواني عشان
للتوضيح في بعض المراقبين بيشوف هون
الرئيس عمر حسن البشير رئيس انتهازي
استخدم الجماعات الاسلاميه واستخدم الخطاب
الاسلامي فقط لدعم سلطته وفي اخرين شايفين
انه هو كادر اخواني وان حكومه الانقاذ
بالكامل ليست الا حكومه الاخوان المسلمين
اذا كان الكلام دا صحيح ما تم تمكين جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وكوادرها في كل مؤسسات
الدوله بما فيها الجيش و بيرتبوا على كده
ال وزير الدفاع ورئيس اركانه الكوادر
الاخوانيه جاءت من الخطوط ال الخلفيه
للجماعه بتقود الجيش اه في هذه الفتره
العصيبه
وبالتالي هم بيعتقدوا انه ال ما جرى هو
محاوله من الاخوان اللي تجميل صوتهم
البقاء في السلطه عن طريق التخلص من عدد
من العناصر فقط طيب ما هو ده بالظبط اللى
بيعملوا النظام لما يكون في ازمه صحيح لكن
اذا كانوا هم اخواننا يترتب عليه عده امور
مختلفه شويه رقم واحد ان القتال للدفاع عن
بقائهم في السلطه سوف يكون اكثر شراسه لان
من يدافع عن مصالحه يصبح اكثر شراسه اذا
كان يدافع عن مصالحه تحت شعارات دينيه
وبيكون عند ال قدره اكبر على تجنيد عدد
اكبر من ال الميليشيات او من الكوادر من
داخل السودان ومن خارج السودان من
الراغبين في الدفاع عن المشروع الاسلامي
كما يتصورون الامر الثاني انه بردو الدفاع
يكون اكثر شراسه لان جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين تلقت مجموعه كبيره من الضربات
منذ العام 2013
في عدد من الدول وبالتالي عدد الدول اللي
يرحب جماعه الاخوان المسلمين محدود في
حاله السودان مش بس يرحب جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين يسمح لهم بالوصول الى حرب السلطه
واصعب انهم يتخلوا عنه الامر الثالث اذا
ثبت اه هذا الافتراض
النظام باكمله اخواني بمعنى انه يكون
النظام امتدادات خارج السوداني في دول
اه سوف يعني تذهب الى اقصى المدى للدفاع
عنه اذا كانت قطر اذا كانت تركيه اذا كان
جماعه الاخوان وجهازها وهم مجمعه م ادله
نفوذ كبير في كثير من دول العالم في
المقابل سوف تسارع دول اخرى تقف في
المعسكر الاخر زي مصر وفي الامارات
والسعوديه ودول اخرى في محاوله ل الهجوم
المضاد على بقايا جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
والتاكد من عدم تمكنها من البقاء في
السلطه لثلاثين عاما اخرى معنى كده يترتب
عليه حرب بالوكاله في على اراضي السودان
هو النظام والدوله تعاني من مشاكل كثيره
قد يعقد الامور بشكل كبير الحقيقه اللي
انا عاوز اقول وا بايجاز شديد جدا انه ال
الفتره اللي جايه هي لها تكشف لنا بوضوح
حقيقه توجهات وزاره الدفاع او الجيش اه
الحقيقيه ممكن امور كثيره منها مثلا اسماء
اللي يتم اختيارهم للمجلس الانتقالي طريقه
تعامله مع المتظاهرين مط مطالبتهم
المتصاعده لا يكون عنصر مؤثر جدا في
الاحداث في الفتره القادمه في عنصر اخر
مؤثر وهي
حسابات الدول الخارجيه كل دول العالم وترك
بما يجري في هذا البلد المهم ان يكون
تصورها لمصالحها في السودان وفي افريقيا
دور مؤثر في مسار الاحداث
اذا كان فيما يتعلق بالولايات المتحده
وروسيا بريطانيا فرنسا كل الدول اللي انا
اشرت اليها
بالاضافه طبعا الى كل الدول الافريقيه في
اثيوبيا وزير الجزائر وزي الكثير من دول
الجوار اللي ما يجري في السودان يؤثر على
امنها القومي بشكل مباشر اشكركم في انتظار
البيان الثاني والثالث للمجلس العسكري
ادعو الله ان يحفظ السودان واهله من كل
سوء الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]